to you about like well what do i do if i
don't feel like writing and you were
like oh
you don't feel like writing
oh
it's like well then don't be a comedian
you know it's like you got to be willing
to put in the work or you know just
don't complain about what you're not
doing basically
yeah if a farmer gets up in the morning
i don't feel like doing the chores and i
want to feed the chickens i'm tired
you don't have the option and the better
comedians think of it like farming you
get up and you do it whether you like it
or not it doesn't really matter
yeah i remember that conversation that
was a lot of fun
yeah is is that what your kind of your
mindset around your new podcast because
you're releasing it every week and it's
all new materials so was it something to
kind of spark your creative juices and
get you some accountability
exactly so i love accountability i've
always loved having a weekly deadline
where i have to produce work
because yeah some weeks you're not gonna
be feeling good and you're not gonna be
feeling funny or whatever but
if i have a show where i have to be
funny or try to be funny for like 15
minutes it's just me in front of the
camera then i'm going to come up with
something you know and i'll do my best
and i love that i love the energy of
that and i kept compiling these comedy
ideas i would have this list going of oh
that's a funny observation or oh that
could be a good bit or whatever
and then
with the pandemic i wasn't going out as
much
and
then
even when the pandemic came back like
college lecture series corporate work
has not really returned in with full
gusto
i figured you know what i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna do this and
yeah it's kind of a big lifestyle change
to to sign up to do a weekly tv show but
um
it's good for me it's good for me i need
it and so i'm yeah i'm doing comedy and
i'm doing little
skits and little goofs and impressions
and animation
uh just like throwing everything in the
pot and just trying to have fun and do
something that i
my whole thing is i don't want to just
do what everybody else is doing so i'm
just doing something that feels very me
and
that just like
is a way for me to
express my unique sense of humor and
hopefully it connects with people who
have a similar sense of humor it's
obviously very different than going on
stage because you have no idea what the
audience is thinking
you know
did that most of my career i worked at
uh as a comic strip artist as a
voiceover artist and as an editor of the
onion never knew what the audience
thought had to had to make the stuff and
then put it out there and just hope and
so i'm doing the same thing now it's a
little different when you're performing
it somehow i don't know what what it is
about that but when it's you out there
and you don't have some facade of comic
strip characters or fake newspaper or
something else
you you do crave that
immediate response from the audience to
know oh did this joke work but i don't
care like i you know
like bill burke can do an hour podcast a
week where he just rants
and he doesn't care whether he's funny
he's just talking he'll talk about
sports for half an hour
so
i can i can do that i can i can try to
be funny and
sometimes i hit sometimes i miss and
it's good like
the key to quality is quantity so the
more i produce the more really good
material i'm gonna have
and so whenever i
do have a chance to hit the stage
which i just for lifestyle reasons i
just don't do as much as i should
i have like this huge
catalog of material that i can draw on
that i've developed for the from this
show so it's kind of like my way of
forcing myself to write
i love it yeah that's that's how the our
daily writing club started like all
right 10 clubs started literally because
i was like oh my gosh there's a pandemic
i have no idea when or if i'm going back
to comedy if i don't have accountability
i'm not gonna write and it literally
started with me like
okay here's my webcam
i'm just gonna write for 10 minutes
here's what i came up with and then
people started participating organically
and it just evolved from there but it
all stemmed from i need accountability
to write or i won't
yeah